- You are just someone in the
know, you always have been.
One of the things that we've
been doing here on the show
is focusing on small business gift guides.
We're gonna include some of the businesses
for Valentine's day and
Easter, and, you know,
listen every holiday possible
as well as general gift giving.
What do you think?
Like, what is Elaine
Welteroth's three items
that you would recommend to our viewers?
- All right, first of all,
I would say everybody in the quarantine
needs a pair of Melody Ehsani sweat suit.
So Melody Ehsani is a woman of color.
- By the way, I'm such a fan
of hers and I've totally -
- [Elaine] You know her too?
- Oh yeah and she's -
- You have to have her on the show.
I have to tell you, everybody
needs a great sweatsuit,
like a cozy, comfy sweatsuit
to just live in for the quarantine
and all I wear when I'm not
on the Drew Barrymore show
wearing sequins,
I am in my canary yellow
Melody Ehsani sweatsuit
so that's one.
- Also that's super on trend.
Like sweat suits.
- [Elaine] Oh is it?
- [Drew] Very much so,
like the big thing of 2021
is like tie dye and
like head to toe sweats.
- I highly recommend that.
- [Drew] Okay, perfect.
- Now I would also say,
because again, the quarantine,
and I have to shout out a beauty brand.
'Cause you know, once a beauty editor,
always a beauty editor.
- [Drew] I love me some beauty.
So tell us, Elaine,
what beauty item?
- [Elaine] Well you're gonna,
you're gonna fall in love with this brand
and also this man.
So Vernon Francois is a hairstylist.
He specializes in wavy,
curly and kinky textures
and he's just, he's incredible.
You have to follow him on
Instagram, first of all,
Vernon Francois, you will thank me later.
He has a whole line of products
that are at Sally Beauty.
And he makes this
incredible hydrating mist
that for those of you who like me
just don't really have time
to wash your hair that often,
especially in the quarantine
where you're like going
from Zoom to Zoom, to Zoom
and you're not really going outside
so you don't really have
a lot of motivation.
This is the best product
to refresh your hair.
So if you're on like day three, day four,
and you're like, things
are getting a little,
a little, they're going left,
you can just spray your hair down.
It has this incredible
mist, it's super fine
so it's not going to wet your hair down
if you have a blowout or
a texture that you know,
you're trying to preserve,
but you just put it in
and you kind of do this and
it just gives the life back.
It looks like you're on
day one or day two again.
So that's my little secret
weapon through the quarantine.
- I will be purchasing that today, okay,
not kidding.
- Boom!
- I literally, I wish
there was a closeup of me
'cause I was like this.
Like I too definitely
delay the hair washing
and look for fresheners
so I'm gonna,
- [Elaine] Who has time?
- I'm gonna buy that today
and start following him.
Okay, number three.
- Okay, now number three
isn't necessarily a small business,
but you can purchase it
from a small indie bookstore
and it would be Barack Obama's
latest book, A Promised Land.
It is 700 pages of magic, it's so good.
So I would get that for anyone on my list.
- Well, and I want to give kudos to you
because I saw your interview with him
and you could even tell that he was happy
with the question you asked.
He said, oh,
- Oh, thank you.
That's a great question.
And -
- I was freaking out about that.
Afterwards I was like,
he hated my question.
He hated my question, did we have a vibe?
Did we have a vibe? I don't know.
Are we friends yet? Like I freaked out.
So thank you for the vote of confidence.
- No, I know it's your birthday recently
and we got you
- Yes.
- A little surprise,
oh, thank you, Daniel.
Poor Daniel, how long have
you been holding that candle?
Thank you so much.
So I heard
your favorite flavor
- [Elaine] Oh my gosh.
- Is red velvet, is this true?
- That is true.
- [Drew] Phew, okay, good, well -
- Drew, thank you.
- Elaine Welteroth,
- How do I get it from you?
- I'm gonna walk it over here
and I'm gonna put it right here for you,
there you go
and it's a little happy birthday to you
and -
- This is my first birthday gift.
- [Drew] Oh, good!
- Because it's the quarantine
and I can't see anybody.
- [Drew] I know.
- So thank you.
- Let's high five over the airwaves
and let's do more check ins.
- Woo!
- And be sisters in TV.
We've been sisters in beauty.
- I love this, aw.
- And I'm so happy for this next chapter
and all of the risks that you've taken
that brought you here to this moment
so you're just the raddest.
- Thank you.
- And beginning January 4th,
you're gonna catch Elaine on The Talk
which airs weekdays,
2pm, 1pm Central, on CBS.
- I love you.
I love you,
thank you so much
- I love you so much.
- For having me on the show.
- Quite the opposite,
I'll come visit you,
anything I can ever do
- [Elaine] Please.
- For you, with you, I've always -
- Does this mean you're
gonna come on as our guest?
Did I hear that?
You're coming on as our guest?
- Elaine, you call,
- [Elaine] On The Talk?
- I will be there in a heartbeat.
(upbeat pop music)